hey guys I know welcome back to the
channel we have an exciting video for
you it is our honeymoon video how it's a
honeymoon
it's fun I like that it was really
relaxing no stress and the schedule
nothing and like we weren't trying to be
on her phones at all so because of that
this video is a combination of all the
days with just random little quits
because we were trying really hard to
just be the two of us just enjoy each
other's company for our honeymoon so
this video is a little bit different our
honeymoon video is brought to you by
audible Thank You audible and it was
pretty cool having audible at hand
because the entire train ride from Paris
to Barcelona was about six hours so
during that time I took advantage of
audible and I was listening to
mindfulness in plain English and it's
like this book that I've been worried
I've been really trying to get into my
wholeness ever since like he got into it
it really changed his life completely so
like okay I gotta try to get into it
I've been pretty bad about being
consistent but reading that book cuz
that entire book was actually like
6-hour like a little bit more than six
hours so I get to finish the book during
that train ride but it was like pretty
much the entire train ride I was
listening to it and yeah I was pretty
cool like learning different like
anchors and like things to really focus
on so I was something else really
enjoying every time we filmed a video go
crazy like they know it's like hey I
want to be in the video too
I heard I'm using the kitty litter too
just now so audio like getting to shine
I'm gonna ruin your wardrobe but anyways
yeah yeah the books called color water
by James McBride it's one of my all-time
favorite books ever and it's the one
book that I've actually reread multiple
times now check out the book its James
McBride color of water so audible is an
online subscription based service where
you can tune in to different audio
books podcast just about anything that's
audio based you can tune in and listen
to it and it's pretty amazing if you
don't like reading check out audible
they'll read it to you and you can just
listen I'm a happy customer cause I hate
reading so if you want your own free
30-day trial membership make sure to
check out our link it's in the
description it's audible.com slash tip
in case and it should be on the screen
right here too so you go and get
yourself a free audible membership and
then you can start listening to books
and then just maybe check out the books
that we recommend it so anyways without
further ado check out our honeymoon
radio and enjoy it see you guys next
time
hi what are we doing today today we're
leaving we're leaving our wedding B & B
everyone left
yesterday's we've been home alone and
now heading over cuz we're heading to
the train station and we're going up to
Barcelona on our honeymoon I'm just
ready to get some sleep cuz or cilona is
six hours away yeah I'm excited to be
leaving this house because I was telling
TIFF earlier that I'm starting to get
the wedding blues if that's the thing I
don't know just since everyone's leaving
the energy of Paris and the energy of
this house is completely different I'm -
sunshine rainbows
[Music]
that's one way to get back we're gonna
do one together
[Music]
[Applause]
all right touchdown
Barcelona we're in Barcelona now because
of there were these girls on the train
ahead McDonald's and I was craving my
dollar I think in the last like four
hours so it's a very first meal in
Barcelona what is that McDonald CBO
cycle - um perspective Covina
[Applause]
I thought it was interesting that the
large and the medium no oh yeah I mean I
took the same size it's like there's no
difference here
but even that's a medium back in the
States Americans are cutting this yes
they got the grant extreme from
McDonald's that does not look like the
the picture in the menu when does it
ever match the picture in the menu
[Music]
looks nice Leflore me on oh yeah it
looked really good in as lighting yeah
every year top floor just like JK
honeymoon mystery tour we had a jacuzzi
my the room and then and then in bed
are you kidding me oh I don't they were
anything just bang I mean this is
and feel as though my full body burned
everything this is the first time I've
ever had staircases you know my hotel
room this is free so I didn't take a
look at the downstairs yet this is so
cool we're gonna turn up all right so
our hotels have been away from the city
it's what we could afford and it's what
we could cookbook at the time too so
ideally we would want all this within
the city right next to beach overlooking
the city and beach but we thought we
could always just kind of taxi it back
into the city which is only like 15
minutes away but yeah we I mean this is
affording this was I think priority
number one for us only because it's a
honeymoon and we want to treat ourselves
out for once in terms of having some
luxury for our stay there we got two
bathrooms in one hotel room you can poop
down here I'll destroy this one down
here and I'll keep the one upstairs
enjoy this room let's do it check this
out
look at that so everything like you
think could it's because this girl
with French accent and she kept saying
cool like that she was I could still
could so I really liked it whoa it's
dark in here in the world the tiniest
little ice bucket see our decided today
we're gonna know just enjoy the hotel
since it's already kind of late to begin
with go out so bring it up just make a
day out of
tomorrow for Spanish tourists coming
over tours in Spain Spanish everything
is really sharp over here all right stay
two of Barcelona and here we go really
counts touka is our first full day so I
would say this is our eighth one all
right day one Barcelona day two
honeymoon
[Music]
I think so it's more caustic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right so so far my impression of
this place it's kind of like a Spanish
dim sum place because the top stars like
dim sums I like Spanish it it's empty
you got wine or
[Music]
it's good oh man you don't you're like
anchovies
oh no some red ham really really right
now oh yeah hey this one right here is
what I'm really looking for sir this is
razor clams never had a razor fans
before they're like speedy clams this is
the best thing yet that this thing with
delicious
[Music]
[Music]
this is designed by the famous Spanish
guy I forgot the name of we can do a
quick Google search give them the right
credit yeah lose your phone you have
more service than me really really good
okay so it's Antoni gaudí Gaudi
Gaudi just remember his name
GoPro would do this justice
[Music]
oh no this is way taller than any other
sugar Ben for sure
I remember it seemed that time ceiling
this is freaking tall opening Oh based
on me with my dad
it's 7:30 p.m. face time you see this
church behind me this is the craziest
looking church I've ever seen in my life
alright so when in Rome but rather when
in Spain you deal with the local stew
and it seems like every local here is
enjoying their Sunday off but just today
is a Sunday and we're enjoying our
Sunday off too because we're not we're
not doing anything we didn't we didn't
have an agenda today we kind of just
slept in really late woke up late got
out some hotel really late had a late
lunch and then visited the the church we
only did one thing today which is that
church over there and it's very nice
it's so nice like thank you mom and dad
for taking care Isaac because it's been
a it's been a pleasure having a break
and just living life with just the two
of us and then honestly this has only
been the first date but
vacation so far because there's no
agenda no schedule like no one else to
worry about or like having to meet up
with anyone there's not have to worry
about anyone else but just just so
relaxed it's no rush
yeah relaxing to max and chilling so
chilling and maxin relaxin is that the
words drilling max and relax and I don't
know Fresh Prince
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we gotta get food sorry so we just
stopped at a random spot inside this
market and we just saw our neighbor over
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before my life
alright today we face that extremely
very good extremely very good and the
main events of the meal is crap time
ladies clothes
[Music]
we got a little thirsty
a little bit of fresh juice strawberry
coconut
the manga from the fruits and guess what
I just pulled out of my purse he loved
you so much I brought you all the way to
Barcelona I don't even know if they
spell you here but I love you did you
know that that means from well no matter
what really yeah it's really good it's
from where my people are from my family
I love you so much
straight from Mexico to Spain I mean the
drinks are really small I wish this
drink was big I went to McDonald's
supersize me portion of this you're in
Europe you're not gonna get that I know
what I didn't like hand me a bit of
appetizer there
[Applause]
okay the one that has less oh you had a
big fan for a good to die mean his
mangoes BOM mangoes
oh my god Spain's fruit game is on point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like chili
amazing it's a beautiful city very chill
and laid-back Oh
[Music]
after a day of wandering around me miss
taco a restaurant a nicely restaurant
it's very quite you're not eating dinner
yes your OCD takes over while eating
mussels
what is Russian dolls where you have
been wide enough to another you don't
have like a huge mess like where as
eventually mine is gonna be like
everywhere this is the og jambalaya
arrow CD that's alright very organized
vo that's Bo
save me some glam and you can play it
nor am i sorry I'm sure your eyes and
light up oh you should try some paella
from another place and little compare
and contrast and we'll figure out what
bit pie it is they rushed it resent a
shrimp that's a prawn that's the shrimp
that's a prawn I don't know I really
don't know I don't know anything about
food finally halfway in your mouth and
it's like slowly came out to be a foodie
you don't know nothing about them that's
the thing it may be a basketball head
but not very good at basketball
you could be a cantar head but not be
very good at playing guitar you have to
know how to play the guitar that you
could be like I love guitar solo Kamal
got guitars I love food but I just know
what it's my turn
good I like it my tummy holes are you
busted
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right what are we doing now are we
eating Mexican food heads you brought up
a good point you're like in Paris like
since the French colonized Vietnam
there's a lot of Vietnamese people and
France and so like the flow is really
good in France vanish colonize Mexico
there must be some really good micro
years as well plus I miss my food that's
over here I want to try it out then top
spot got a really high rating so it's
gonna be hard to impress they're from LA
and LA he's got some the best Mexican
food outside of Mexico so good luck
pretty minute it's not that good it's
more of the experience of finding out
I'm just curious as to what Europe's
interpretation of Mexican food would be
like you know especially Spain so
good they're so cute look at the little
tiny gets idea
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like if you go to Italy pizza there the
pizzas really like rocks is really like
everything is really like there and then
you go to like any other country outside
the US that the burden of Chinese food
is going to be much lighter than the
Chinese food Americanized Chinese we
don't get in u.s.
so yeah so I think the American Standard
American is in like the Americas like up
and down America is at extra sodium
extra salt and extra flavor to
everything whereas the old world the old
countries they can I have more of a
blender or just kind of a lighter touch
to everything so that's the biggest
difference right now so far that she's
pulled pretty good though
just like home feeling good are we not
at the beach though
[Music]
flavor
what's that that's condensed milk and
this is strawberry oh my goodness that's
about it is delicious wonder if they
have other locations because in the u.s.
they need to open in LA in LA
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's cool see the turtles
[Music]
what are you doing it's so hot today oh
that feels so great
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I notice about Spain and your
Europe in general they don't clean out
the poop sorry Americans are just too
picky I could eat this tomato rug bread
for days too so tip after experiencing
Spain a little bit of Spain time in
Spain and Catalonia having experienced
this year you feel more connected here
do you feel more connected when you
visit Mexico heritage wise present mean
there's obviously there's heritage here
somewhere along the way and then we're
only miles away from a city called
Ciudad rial which is literally
translates to the city of royal which is
your last name
city of Rio do you feel more heritage
here or more heritage in Mexico
I feel more connected here because
everyone around me looks like me they do
you don't look Mexican that's why I
thought you were our Manian or something
like that you just don't look Mexican to
me
the way everything is work like well
European live and like everything drinks
petits everything and
which Mexico doesn't know
a lot more connected here
I guess soon as we got here and start
exploring one Street
[Applause]
[Music]
Christmas be Park here and it's like a
gingerbread house with snow tops it's a
delicious part
[Music]
thanks for watching what are you guys
doing alright so it's our last meal
our last dinner we're leaving tomorrow
morning the errand stage we're leaving
tomorrow
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
the seafood here so amazing we're making
sure if we're gonna get sick of before
we leave definitely anyway how you're
used to it if they don't have a new year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we just finished breakfast and we're
walking in yeah it's been ball four
right near the beach we're really close
to the Black Sea but it's on the other
side of the world where we're so close
to it
[Music]
this is a nice way to end our honeymoon
in Turkey all right this is officially
the last light are you ready for this
13-hour flight approximate approximately
cuz I cool of Istanbul this morning to
see where it was exactly on a map cuz I
didn't know I did not know and and
that's at thirteen hours thirteen and
something whooa
twelve hours and forty-seven I crushed
Turkish Airlines today we're in the
business
you know what is creepy Barcelona
we don't ever because I got [ __ ] on my
ankle
get cankles now and then these well they
swelled up so big that were actually
painful for me to walk in these past two
days like on it like
see here my ankle has been rolled up so
badly usually you can see my ankle bone
but here it's like gone and your
Achilles tendon is really defined yeah
it's very defined but not here it's just
like so swollen and then right here is
the bite mark I don't know like usually
mosquitoes don't leave that kind of a
mark on my ankles but this ankle that
was bitten more recently so it's the
more swollen but it was actually fatter
like yesterday it was pretty big but
then this one and getting there not yet
still very swollen you still can't see
my bone and then this when I first got
this was the first mosquito bite I got
so I scratched it a lot so I think I
just made the bite mark worse but this
entire area was so fat like my shoes
can't even close with my shoes they're
like right hearing it who was the
previous thing to look I've never seen
this anything else
but if I push down really really hard I
can actually like mold my skin I've
never I've never happened to me guys
like do you know what happened to me cuz
this is crazy like there's so much like
fluid or I don't know what this is but
it's like I can actually mold this like
this is insane I don't know what bit me
but firstly I know that on your ankles
yeah that's what it feels like and then
this entire thing just feels really hot
and itchy like I just want to scratch so
bad right now this effect only
my ankles I got busy my calves
on my wrist and it's not that bad here I
don't know what happened to my ankles
but it was really painful to walk to the
flag couple days my English
really boring to go Foreman just
we have to film ticket partying today
for takeoff
[Music]